what's up guys bang bang this week's
bitcoin update is coming to you live
from the road new york city i'm
traveling this week but i wouldn't miss
these updates you'll probably hear my
nine-month-old daughter going
in the background in a few minutes and
also my wife she keeps snacking so
you'll probably hear a lot of crinkling
of potato bag chips too don't forget
that these updates they're brought to
you by ftx you can click on the link in
the description to learn more about them
let's jump into this week's update and
see what the hell is going on with
bitcoin's price to get started we can
see that bitcoin is now trading just
below twenty thousand dollars not
exactly what we want to see bitcoins
market cap now about 375 billion dollars
or so the inflation rate is still
sitting at 1.76
and over 90 of bitcoin has been issued
into the circulating supply we can see
the real exchange volume has come down
significantly and now less than six
billion dollars being traded in a
24-hour period in that same time period
miners have been paid 18.4 million
dollars to continue to secure the
bitcoin network gbtc is now trading at a
32 discount and bitcoin is now down 71
from its all-time high of 69 000 back in
november of last year if we compare
bitcoin gold and the s p 500 we can see
that bitcoin down 60 percent over a 12
month period but over a two to ten year
time frame bitcoin continues to
outperform both gold and s p 500
then we can look at bitcoin's price
closing history and sitting below 20 000
means that bitcoin is traded above this
position 610 days of its lifetime which
means that if you had bought and held 87
of bitcoin's days and held it until
today you would still be in profit then
if we go and take a look bitcoin gold s
p 500 nasdaq and tlt you can see that
the compound annual growth rate of
bitcoin coming in at 113
continues to outperform these other
assets and bitcoin's five-year sharp
ratio just below 0.8 means that if you
add it to a diversified portfolio it
would have an incredibly positive impact
the last thing that i want to talk about
is the energy crisis that seem to be
playing out in europe now of course this
doesn't have a direct impact on
bitcoin's price not very many people are
buying oil and dropping bitcoin or vice
versa buying bitcoin and dropping oil
but what we do see is that the
geopolitical chess game is underway
there's reports that are now surfacing
that many countries like germany and
others they are in a dire situation we
are seeing on the ground whether it's
individuals or businesses they're
reporting that their electricity bills
are going parabolic that obviously
spells trouble going into the winter in
europe but also there's other things
that seem to be happening there's
reports coming out that russia is now
selling oil to china who then turns
around and is immediately just putting
up the price they're marking it up and
then they're selling it to those
european countries this allows the
european countries to claim well virtue
signal that they're not buying russian
oil but also means that china they're
playing market maker and they're making
a damn good profit doing it on top of
that we've also seen countries like
hungary who all of a sudden stood up and
said we're not playing this game anymore
we're gonna strike deals with the
russian energy companies because we need
the energy in order to make sure our
people are safe
then just in the last 48 hours we've
seen russia come out and they've said
you know what nordstrom won we're gonna
shut that bad boy down we're having some
technical issues we'll let you know when
it comes back online
of course there's all sorts of
complexities involved in this but when
you see energy prices exploding upwards
that's a big problem on top of that if
you wanted to actually drive gdp growth
both in the united states and globally
what would you do you would have low
interest rates and you'd have real wage
growth but we're seeing the exact
opposite here in the united states
interest rates are going up while we're
in a recession on top of that we're also
seeing real wages people are actually
making less and less money 16 of the
last 18 months they've made less money
than they were previously so this spells
complete trouble now why does that all
matter as the global financial system
gets in a more dire situation it becomes
harder and harder for the federal
reserve to actually raise interest rates
and create tighter financial conditions
they saying that they are committed to
doing that and so far they've held true
to their work but at some point they're
going to have to pivot they'll have to
waive that white flag the big question
in finance right now is will the central
banks both the federal reserve and those
around the world are they going to
capitulate before the end of 2022 or
will this carry into 2023 and at some
point then we'll return to a loose
monetary policy between 1940 and 2021
the average debt to gdp ratio in america
was sitting around 68
now we have nearly 140 debt to gdp
this means that the central bank cannot
raise interest rates to the move at some
point they have to stop and we will
return to that loose monetary policy
when that happens bitcoin risk assets
growth stocks and many other things that
most of you have in your portfolio they
will likely then have a resurgence and a
recovery and return back to all-time
highs but until that moment the federal
reserve they are in control and so far
they are continuing to punish the market
in their quest to destroy consumer
demand it's working but at some point
they'll have to stop and that's what i
expect much better news for bitcoin and
other risk assets i hope that you're
enjoying these weekly updates i enjoy
putting them together even when i'm on
the road but these updates are now
brought to you by ftx you can go you can
buy bitcoin and cryptocurrencies with
really cheap fees sometimes as much as
85 cheaper than their competitors they
also recently introduced digital stock
trading that has no payment for order
flow and no transaction fees so you get
great pricing go check out ftx today you
can click on the link in the description
they continue to innovate in financial
markets and i think that you'll really
enjoy using their product go check them
out keep watching these weekly updates
i'll put out the next one next saturday
and let me know in the comments if
you're enjoying them and what we can do
to make them better that's it for this
week and i'll see you guys next saturday